The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Having already studied area
and volume and its
relationship to calculus, today,
we turn our attention
to the study of length.
And this may seem a bit strange
because, intuitively,
I think it's fair to assume that
you would imagine that
length would be simpler than
area which, in turn, would be
simpler than volume and, hence,
that perhaps we should
have started with length
in the first place.
The interesting thing is in
terms of our structure, which
we so far have called
two-dimensional area,
three-dimensional area, and
which, today, we shall call
one-dimensional area, a rather
peculiar thing that causes a
great deal of difficulty,
intellectually speaking,
occurs in the study of arc
length that does not occur in
either the study of
area or volume.
And I think that we'll start
our investigation today
leading up to what this
really means.
So, as I say, I call today's
lesson 'One-dimensional Area',
which is arc length.
And let's show that there is a
parallel, at least in part,
between the structure of arc
length and the structure of
area and volume.
You may recall that for area,
our initial axiom was that the
building block of area
was a rectangle.
And for volumes, the building
block we saw was a cylinder.
For arc length--
I think it's fairly obvious
to guess what
we're going to say--
the basic building block is
a straight line segment.
And so without further ado, that
becomes our first rule,
our first axiom, axiom
number one.
We assume that we can measure
the length of any straight
line segment.
That's our building block.
The second axiom that we assume
is that the length of
the whole equals the sum of
the lengths of the parts.
In other words, if an arc is
broken down into constituent
bases, the total arc length is
equal to the sum of the arc
lengths of the constituent
parts.
And at this stage, we can
say, so far, so good.
This still looks like
it's going to be the
same as area or volume.
But now remember what one of the
axioms for both area and
volume were, namely, what?
That if region 'R' was contained
in region 'S', the
area or the volume of 'R' was
no greater than that of the
area or volume of 'S'.
However, for arc length,
this is not true.
It need not be true.
I shouldn't say it's not true.
It need not be true that if
region 'R' is contained in 'S'
that the perimeter of region 'R'
is less than or equal to
the perimeter of 'S'.
In fact, this little diagram
that I've drawn over here, I
hope will show you what
I'm driving at.
Notice that it's rather clear
that the region 'R' here,
which is shaded, is contained
inside the region 'S', which
is my rectangle.
And yet, if you look at the
perimeter here, all these
finger-shaped things in here, I
think it's easy to see that
the perimeter of 'R' exceeds
the perimeter of 'S'.
And if it's not that easy to
see, heck, just make a few
more loops inside here and
keep wiggling this thing
around until you're convinced
that you have created this
particular situation.
All I want you to see here is
that it's plausible to you
that we cannot talk about
lengths by squeezing them, as
we did areas and volumes,
between regions that we
already knew contained the
given region and were
contained in the given region.
Now let me just pause here for
one moment to make sure that
we keep one thing straight.
We're talking now about an
analytical approach to length.
In other words, an approach that
will allow us to bring to
bear all of the power of
calculus to the study.
I don't want you to forget for
a moment that intuitively, we
certainly do know what arc
length is, just as we
intuitively had a feeling for
what area and volume were.
Just to freshen our memories
on this, remember the
intuitive approach.
That if you have an arc from 'A'
to 'B', the typical way of
measuring the arc length is to
take, for example, a piece of
string, lay it off along the
curve from 'A' to 'B'.
After you've done this,
pick the string up.
And then straighten the string
out, whatever that means, and
measure its length
with a ruler.
And we won't worry about how
you know whether you're
stretching the string too
taut or what have you.
We'll leave out these
philosophic questions.
All we'll say is we would like
a more objective method that
will allow us to use
mathematical analysis.
And so what we're going to try
to do next is to find an
analytic way that will allow us
to use calculus, but at the
same time will give us a
definition which agrees with
our intuition.
And the first question is
how shall we begin.
And as so often is the case in
mathematics, we begin our new
quest by going back to an
old way that worked
for a previous case.
And hopefully, we'll find a
way of extending the old
situation to cover the new.
Now what does this mean in
this particular instance?
Well, let me just
call it this.
I'll call it analytical
approach, trial number one.
What I'm going to do is try to
imitate exactly what we did in
the area case.
For example, if I take the
region 'R', which I'll draw
this way here, if this is the
region 'R', namely bounded
above by the curve 'y' equals 'f
of x', below by the x-axis,
on the left, by the line 'x'
equals 'a', and on the right,
by the line 'x' equals 'b', how
did we find the area of
the region 'R'?
Well, what we did is we
inscribed and we circumscribed
rectangles.
And we took the limit of the
circumscribed rectangles, et
cetera, and put the squeeze on
as 'n' went to infinity.
Now the idea is we might get the
idea that maybe we should
do the same thing
for arc length.
In other words, let me call one
of these little pieces of
arc length 'delta w'.
In other words, I'm just
isolating part
of the diagram here.
Here's 'delta w'.
Here's 'delta x'.
Here's 'delta y'.
The idea is in the same way that
I approximated a piece of
area by an inscribed and a
circumscribed rectangle, why
can't I say something like,
well, let me let 'delta w' be
approximately equal
to 'delta x'?
And just to make sure that our
memories are refreshed over
here, notice that 'delta x' is
just the length of each piece
if the segment from 'a' to 'b',
namely of length 'b - a',
is divided into 'n'
equal parts.
See, the idea is why can't we
mimic the same approach.
And let me point out what is
so crucial here in terms of
what I mentioned above, namely,
notice that the reason
that we can say that the area of
the region 'R' is just the
limit of 'U sub n' as 'n'
approaches infinity, where 'U
sub n' is the area of the
circumscribed rectangles.
The only reason we can say that
is because we squeezed 'A
sub r' between 'L sub n', the
inscribed rectangles, and 'U
sub n', the circumscribed
rectangles.
And the limits of these
lower bounds and
upper bounds were equal.
'A sub 'r was squeezed
between these two.
Hence, it had to equal
the common limit.
That was the structure
that we used.
On the other hand, we can't use
that when we're dealing
with arc length.
And I'll mention that in
a few moments again.
But let me just point out what
I'm driving at this way.
Suppose we mimic this
as we did before.
And we say, OK, let the element
of arc length, 'delta
w', be approximately
equal to 'delta x'.
And now what I will do
is define script
'L' from 'a' to 'b'.
I don't want to call it arc
length because it may not be.
But as a first approximation,
let me define this symbol to
be the limit of the sum of all
these 'delta x's when we
divide this region into 'n'
parts as 'n' goes to infinity.
Now look, I have the right to
make up this particular
definition.
Now if I compute this
limit, what happens?
Recall that we mentioned
that 'delta x' was
'b - a' over 'n'.
Consequently, if I have 'n' of
these pieces, the total sum
would be what?
'n' times b' - a' over 'n'.
And 'n' times 'b - a' over
'n' is just 'b - a'.
In other words, script 'L' from
'a' to 'b' is defined.
And it's 'b - a', not 'w'.
In other words, coming
back to our
diagram, notice what happened.
What we wanted was a recipe
that would give
us this length here.
What we found was a recipe that
gave us the length from
'a' to 'b'.
Now intuitively, we know that
the length from 'a' to 'b' is
not the arc length that
we're looking for.
In other words, what we defined
to be script 'L'
existed as a limit, but it gave
us an answer which did
not coincide with
our intuition.
Since we intuitively know what
the right answer is, we must
discard this approach in the
sense that it doesn't give us
an answer that we have
any faith in.
And by the way, notice where we
went wrong over here if you
want to look at it from
that point of view.
Notice that when we approximated
'delta w' by
'delta x', it's clear from this
diagram that 'delta x'
was certainly less
than 'delta w'.
But notice that we didn't have
an upper bound here.
Or we can make speculations
like, maybe 'delta x + delta
y' would be more than 'delta
w', and things like this.
We'll talk about that
more later.
But for now, all I want us
to see is the degree of
sophistication that enters into
the arc length problem
that didn't bother us in either
the area or the volume
problems, namely, we are missing
now the all-important
squeeze element.
Well, no sense crying
over spilt milk.
We go on, and we try the
next type of approach.
In other words, what we sense
now is why don't we do this.
Instead of approximating 'delta
w' by 'delta x', why
don't we approximate 'delta w'
by the cord that joins the two
endpoints of the arc.
In other words, I think that
we began to suspect
intuitively that, somehow or
other, for a small change in
'delta x', 'delta s' should be
a better approximation to
'delta w' than 'delta x' was.
Of course, the wide open
question is granted that it's
better, is it good enough.
Well, we'll worry about that in
a little more detail later.
All we're saying is let 'delta
w' be approximately
equal to 'delta s'.
In other words, we'll
approximate 'delta
w' by 'delta s'.
And we'll now define 'L' from
'a' to 'b', 'L' from 'a' to
'b' to be the limit not of the
sum of 'delta x's now, but the
sum of the 'delta s's, as 'k'
goes from 1 to 'n', taken in
the limit as 'n' goes
to infinity.
And for those of us who are more
familiar with 'delta x's
and 'delta y's, and the symbol
delta s bothers us, simply
observe that by the Pythagorean
theorem, 'delta s'
is related to 'delta x' and
'delta y' by ''delta s'
squared' equals ''delta
x' squared'
plus ''delta y' squared'.
So we can rewrite this in
this particular form.
In other words, I will define
capital 'L' hopefully to stand
for length later on.
But we'll worry about
that later too.
But 'L' from 'a' to 'b' to
be this particular limit.
And now I claim that there are
three natural questions with
which we must come to grips.
The first question is does
this limit even exist.
Does this limit exist?
And the answer is
that, except for
far-fetched curves, it does.
You really have to get a curve
that wiggles uncontrollably to
break the possibility of
this limit existing.
Unfortunately, there are
pathological cases, one of
which is described in the text
assignment for this lesson, of
a curve that doesn't have a
finite limit when you try to
compute the arc length
this way.
Just a little idiosyncrasy.
However, for any curve that
comes up in real life, that
doesn't oscillate too violently
with infinite
variations, et cetera, et
cetera, which we won't, again,
talk about right now, the idea
is that this limit does exist.
As far as this course is
concerned, we shall assume the
answer to question one is yes.
In fact, the way we'll do it
without being dictatorial is
we'll say, look, if this limit
doesn't exist, we just won't
study that curve.
In fact, we will call
a curve rectifiable
if this limit exists.
And so we'll assume that we
deal only with rectifiable
curves, in other words, that
this limit does exist.
Question number two.
OK, the limit exists.
So how do we compute it?
And that, in general, is not a
very easy thing to answer.
What's even worse though is
that after you've answered
this, you have to come to grips
with a question that we
were able to dodge when we
studied both area and volume,
namely, the question is once
this limit does exist and you
compute it, how do you know
that it agrees with our
intuitive definition
of arc length.
In other words, if you recall
what we did just a few minutes
ago, we defined script 'L'
from 'a' to 'b' to be a
certain limit.
We showed that that
limit existed.
The problem was is that limit,
even though it existed, did
not give us an answer that
agreed intuitively with what
we believed arc length
was supposed to mean.
In other words, you see, we've
assumed the answer to the
first question is yes.
Now we have two questions
to answer.
How do you compute this limit,
which is a hard question in
it's own right?
Secondly, once you do compute
this limit, how do you know
that it's going to agree with
the intuitive answer that you
get for arc length?
And this shall be what we have
to answer in the remainder of
our lesson today.
Let's take these in order.
And let's try to answer question
number two first.
The idea is we've defined
capital 'L' from 'a' to 'b' to
be this particular limit, and
we'd like to know if this
limit exists.
Not only that, but we have a
great command of calculus at
our disposal now.
All of the previous lessons can
be brought to bear here to
help us put this into the
perspective of what calculus
is all about.
For example, when I see an
expression like this, I like
to think in terms
of a derivative.
A derivative reminds me of
'delta y' divided by 'delta
x', et cetera.
So what I do here is I factor
out a ''delta x' squared'.
In other words, I divide through
by ''delta x' squared'
inside the radical sign, which
is really the same
equivalently as dividing
by 'delta x'.
And I multiply by 'delta
x' outside.
In other words, factoring out
with ''delta x' squared', the
square root of ''delta x'
squared' plus ''delta y'
squared' can be written as the
square root of '1 + ''delta y'
over 'delta x'' squared'
times 'delta x'.
Now the idea is that 'delta y'
over 'delta x' is the slope of
that cord that joins the two
endpoints of 'delta w'.
It's not a derivative
as we know it.
It's the slope of a straight
line cord, not
the slope of a curve.
Now the whole idea is this.
We know from the mean value
theorem that if our curve is
smooth, there is a point in
the interval at which the
derivative at that point
is equal to the
slope of the cord.
In other words, if 'f' is
differentiable on [a, b], we
may invoke the Mean
Value Theorem--
here abbreviated as MVT, the
Mean Value Theorem--
to conclude that there is some
point 'c sub k' in our 'delta
x' interval for which ''delta y'
over 'delta x'' is 'f prime
of 'c sub k''.
And in order to help you
facilitate what we're talking
about in your minds, look at
the following diagram.
This is all we're saying.
What we're saying is here's
our 'delta x',
here's our 'delta y'.
We'll call this point 'x
sub 'k - 1'', this
point 'x sub k'.
This is our k-th partition.
'Delta y' divided by 'delta
x' is just the
slope of this line.
See, that's just the
And what the Mean Value Theorem
says is if this curve
is smooth, some place on this
arc, there is a point where
the line tangent to the curve
is parallel to this cord.
And that's what I'm calling
the point 'c sub k'.
'c sub k' is the point at which
the slope of the curve
is equal to the slope
of the cord.
In other words, if 'f' is
continuous, I can conclude
that 'L' from 'a' to 'b' is the
limit as 'n' approaches
infinity, summation 'k' goes
from 1 to 'n', square root of
'1 + ''f prime 'c sub k''
squared' times 'delta x'.
And notice that this now
starts to look like my
definite integral according to
the definition that we were
talking about in our earlier
lectures in this block.
In fact, how can we invoke the
first fundamental theorem of
integral calculus?
Remember, if this expression
here-- it's
not an integral yet--
happens to be a continuous
function, then we're in pretty
good shape.
In other words, if I can assume
that 'f prime' is
continuous--
let's go over here and
continue on here.
See, what I'm saying is if I can
assume that 'f prime' is
continuous, well, look, the
square of a continuous
function is continuous.
The sum of two continuous
functions is continuous.
And the square root of a
continuous function is
continuous.
In other words, and this is a
key point, if the derivative
is continuous, I can conclude
that the 'L' from 'a' to 'b'
can be replaced by the definite
integral from 'a' to
'b' square root of '1 + ''dy/dx'
squared'' times 'dx',
which I quickly point out
may be hard to evaluate.
In other words, one thing I
could try to do over here is
to find the function g whose
derivative with respect to 'x'
is the square root of '1 +
''dy/dx' squared'' and
evaluate that between
'a' and 'b'.
I can put approximations on
here, whatever I want.
In fact, let's summarize
it down here.
If 'f' is differentiable on the
closed interval from 'a'
to 'b' and if 'f prime'
is the derivative--
you see, 'f prime'--
is also continuous on the closed
interval from 'a' to
'b', then not only does capital
'L' from 'a' to 'b'
exist, but it's given
computationally by this
particular integral.
And that answers question number
two, that the limit
exists, and this is what
it's equal to.
The problem that we're
faced with--
and I've written this out.
I think it looks harder
than what it says.
But I've taken the trouble to
write this whole thing out, so
that if you have trouble
following what I'm saying,
that you can see this thing
blocked out for you.
The idea is this.
What we have done is we have
approximated 'delta
w' by 'delta s'.
Then what we said is 'w'
is the sum of all
these 'delta w's.
And since each 'delta w' is
approximately 'delta s', then
what we can be sure of is that
'w' is approximated by this
sum over here.
Now here's what we did.
We didn't work with 'w'
at all after this.
We turned our attention
to this.
This is what we did
in our case here.
And we showed that this
limit existed.
We showed that the limit, as
'k' went from 1 to 'n' and
then went to infinity of these
pieces here, was 'L' of 'ab'.
And that existed.
What we did not show is that
this limit was w itself.
Intuitively, you might say, if
I put the squeeze on this,
doesn't this get rid of
all the error for me?
We haven't shown that we've
gotten rid of all the error.
In essence, how do we know
if all the error has been
squeezed out?
This is precisely what question
three is all about.
Again, going back to what we did
earlier, remember, when we
approximated 'delta w' by 'delta
x', then we said, OK,
add up all these 'delta x's, and
take the limit as 'n' goes
to infinity.
We found that that limit was
'b - a', which was not the
length of the curve.
In other words, somehow or
other, even though the limit
existed, we did not squeeze
out all the error.
And this is why the study of
arc length is so difficult.
Because we don't have a
sandwiching effect.
It is very difficult for us to
figure out when we've squeezed
out all the error.
So at any rate, let
me generalize
question number three.
Remember what question
number three is?
How do we know that if
the limit exists,
it's equal to 'w'?
All I'm saying is don't even
worry about arc length.
Just suppose that 'w' is any
function defined on a closed
interval from 'a' to 'b' and
that we've approximated 'delta
w' by something of the form 'g
of 'c sub k'' times 'delta x',
where 'g' is what I call
some intuitive function
defined on [a, b].
For example, in our earlier
example, we started with
'delta w' being arc length.
And we approximated 'delta w' by
'delta x' in which case 'g'
would've been the function
which is identically 1.
In the area situation, remember
we approximated
'delta A' by something
times 'delta x'.
Well, what times 'delta x'?
Well, it was the height
of a rectangle.
In other words, we look at the
thing we're trying to find, we
use our intuition--
and this is difficult because
intuition varies from person
to person--
and we say, what would make
a good approximation here.
What would be an
approximation?
We say, OK, let's approximate
'delta w' by 'g of 'c sub k''
times 'delta x', where 'c'
is some point in the
interval, et cetera.
Then we add up all of these
'delta w's as 'k'
goes from 1 to 'n'.
We say, OK, that's
approximately
this thing over here.
Now what we have shown is that
if 'g' is continuous on [a, b]
then as 'n' goes to infinity,
this particular limit exists
and is denoted by the
integral from 'a' to
'b', ''g of x' dx'.
This is what we've
shown so far.
What the big question is is,
granted that this limit
exists, does it equal 'w'?
In other words, is 'w' equal
to the integral from 'a' to
b', ''g of x' dx'?
That's what the remainder of
today's lesson is about as far
as arc length is concerned.
And I'm going to solve this
problem in general first and
then make some applications
about this
to arc length itself.
And by the way, what we're going
to see next is you may
remember that very, very early
in our course, we came to
grips with something called
infinitesimals.
We came to grips with this delta
y tan infinitesimals of
higher order.
And now we're going to see how
just as this came up in
differential calculus, these
same problems of approximation
come up in integral calculus.
The only difference, as we've
mentioned before, is instead
of having to come to grips with
the indeterminate form
0/0, we're going to have to
come to grips with the
indeterminate form
infinity times 0.
Let me show you what
I mean by that.
The idea is this.
Let's suppose that our case
'delta w'-- we've broken up
'w' now into increments--
and let's suppose that we're
approximating 'delta w', as we
said before, by 'g of 'c sub
k'' times 'delta x'.
Well, what do we mean by we're
approximating this?
What we mean is there's
some error in here.
Let's call the error 'alpha
sub k' times 'delta x'.
In other words, this is just
a correction factor.
This is what we have to
add on to this to make
this equality whole.
Once I add on the error, I'm
no longer working with an
inequality.
I'm working with an equality.
And that allows me to
use some theorems.
What I can say now is by
definition, w is the sum of
all these 'delta w's.
But 'delta w' being a sum, we
can use theorems about the
sigma notation.
In other words, what is the sum
of all these 'delta w's?
It's the sum of all of these
pieces plus the sum of all of
these pieces, which I've
written over here.
And now you see, if I transpose,
I get that 'w'
minus this sum is equal to the
'sum k' goes from 1 to 'n',
'alpha k' times 'delta x'.
Now the next thing I do
is take the limit
as 'n' goes to infinity.
By definition, since 'g' is a
continuous function, this
limit here is just the definite
integral from 'a' to
'b', ''g of x' dx'.
On the other hand, this limit
here is what we have to
investigate.
In other words, we would like
to know whether 'w' is equal
to the definite integral
or not.
If we look at this particular
equation, what we have now
shown is whatever the
relationship is between these
two terms, it's typified by the
fact that this difference
is this particular limit.
In other words, if this limit
happens to be 0, then the
integral will equal what we're
setting out to show it's equal
to, namely, this function
itself.
On the other hand, what we're
saying is we do not know that
this limit is 0.
By the way, notice what's
happening over here.
As 'n' goes to infinity, 'delta
x' is going to 0.
In other words, each individual
term in the sum is
going to 0, but the number of
pieces is becoming infinite.
There's your infinity
times 0 form here.
And let me show you a case where
the pieces are growing
too fast in number to be offset
by the fact that their
size is going to 0.
For the sake of argument, let me
suppose that 'alpha sub k'
happens to be some non-0
constant for all 'k'.
If I come back to this
expression here, if 'alpha sub
k' is equal to a constant, I'll
replace 'alpha sub k' by
that constant, which is 'c'.
I now have what?
That the limit that I'm looking
for is the 'sum k'
goes from 1 to 'n', 'c' times
'delta x', taking the limit as
'n' goes to infinity.
'c' is a constant, so I
can take it outside
the integral sign.
Since 'c' is a constant and
it's outside the integral
sign, let's look at
what 'delta x' is.
'Delta x' is 'b - a' divided
by 'n', same as we were
talking about earlier
in the lecture.
I have 'n' of these pieces.
The 'n' in the denominator
cancels the 'n' in the
numerator when I add these up.
And notice that this particular
sum here, no matter
what 'n' is, is just 'b - a'.
In other words, in the case
that 'alpha sub k' is a
constant, notice that this limit
is 'c' times 'b - a'.
'c' is not 0.
'b' is not equal to 'a'.
We have an interval here.
Therefore, this will not be 0.
And notice that if this is
not 0, these two things
here are not equal.
And by the way, the aside that
I would like to make here is
that even though this error is
not negligible, notice the
fact that if 'alpha sub k' is
a constant that as 'delta x'
goes to 0, this whole
term will go to 0.
But it doesn't go to
0 fast enough.
In other words, eventually,
we're taking this sum as 'n'
goes to infinity.
And here's a case where, what?
The pieces went to 0, but not
fast enough to become
negligible.
Well, let me give you something
in contrast to this.
Situation number two is suppose
instead 'alpha k' is a
constant times 'delta x'.
'B' times 'delta x', where
'B' is a constant.
In that case, notice that
summation 'k' goes from 1 to
'n', 'alpha k' times 'delta x'
is just summation 'k' goes
from 1 to 'n', 'B' times
''delta x' squared'.
Now keep in mind again that
'delta x' is still
'b - a' over 'n'.
So ''delta x' squared',
of course, is 'b
- a' over 'n squared'.
Notice that what's inside the
summation sign here does not
depend on 'k'.
It's a constant.
I can take it outside
the summation sign.
How many terms of this
size do I have?
Well, 'k' goes from 1 to 'n', so
I have 'n' of those pieces.
Therefore, this sum
is given by this.
This is an 'n squared' term.
One of the 'n's in the
denominator cancels with my
'n' in the numerator.
And in this particular case, I
find that the sum, as 'k' goes
from 1 to 'n', 'alpha sub k'
times 'delta x', is 'B', which
is a constant, times ''b - a'
squared', which is also a
constant, divided by 'n'.
Now look, if I now allow 'n'
to go to infinity, my
numerator is a constant.
My denominator is 'n'.
As 'n' goes to infinity,
my denominator
increases without bound.
My numerator remains constant.
So the limit is 0.
In other words, in the case
where 'alpha sub k' is a
constant times 'delta x', this
limit is 0, the error is
squeezed out, and, in this
particular case, 'w' is given
by the integral from 'a' to 'b',
''g of x' dx' exactly in
this particular situation.
Well, the question is how many
situations shall we go through
before we generalize.
And the answer is since this
lecture is already becoming
quite long, let's generalize now
without any more details.
And the generalization
is this.
In general, if you break down
'w' into increments, which
we'll call 'delta 'w sub
k'', and 'delta 'w sub
k'' is equal to--
well, I've made a little
slip here.
That should be a 'g' in here.
I'm using 'g's rather
than 'f's.
If 'delta 'w sub k'' is 'g of
'c sub k'' times 'delta x'
plus the correction factor
'alpha k' times 'delta x',
and, for each 'k', the limit
of 'alpha k' as 'delta x'
approaches 0 is 0.
In other words, what we're
saying is that 'alpha sub k'
times 'delta x' must be a higher
order infinitesimal.
If this is a higher order
infinitesimal, if 'alpha k'
goes to 0 as 'delta x' goes
to 0, that says, what?
That 'alpha k' times 'delta x'
is going to 0 much faster than
'delta x' itself.
So you compare this with our
discussion on infinitesimals
earlier in our course.
I think that was in block two,
but that's irrelevant here.
But all I'm saying is if that
is the case, in that
particular case, the limit, that
integral is exactly what
we're looking for.
The error has been
squeezed out.
In other words, now, in
conclusion, what we must do in
our present problem to answer
question number three,
remember, we have approximated
delta wk by this intricate
little thing, '1 + ''f prime
'c sub k' squared'
times 'delta x'.
In other words, in our
particular illustration in
this lecture, the role of 'g'
is played by the square root
of '1 + 'f prime squared''.
What we must show is that this
difference is a higher order
differential.
And this really requires much
more advanced work than we
really want to go into.
The only trouble is, as a
student, I always used to be
upset when the instructor said,
the proof is beyond our
ability or knowledge.
Whenever he used to say, the
proof is beyond our knowledge
at this stage of the game, I
used to say to myself, ah, he
doesn't know how to prove it.
I think there's something
upsetting about this.
So what I'm going to try to do
for a finale here is to at
least give you a plausibility
argument that we really do
squeeze the error out in
our approximation of
'delta w' in this case.
In other words, let me draw this
little diagram to bring
in the infinitesimal
idea here.
Here's my 'delta w'.
Here's my 'delta s'.
And what I'm doing now is I am
going to take the tangent line
to the curve at 'A', use that
rather than 'delta x'.
In other words, what I'm going
to say is we're going to
assume that our curve doesn't
have infinite oscillations.
So I can assume the special
case of a monotonically
increasing function, use the
intuitive approach that in
this diagram, 'delta w' is
caught between 'delta s' and
'AB' plus 'BC', observing that
'BC' is just what's called
'delta y' minus 'delta y-tan'.
And that, by the Pythagorean
theorem, 'AB' is the square
root of ''delta x' squared'
plus ''delta 'y sub tan''
squared', which, of course, can
be written this particular
way, namely, notice that the
slope here is the slope of
this curve when 'x' is equal
to 'x sub 'k - 1''.
And again, this is written out,
so I think you can fill
in the details as part of your
review of the lecture and your
homework assignment.
All I want to do here is
present a plausibility
argument using 'AB', 'AC', and
'delta s' as they occur in
this diagram.
All we're saying is, look, if
we're willing to make the
assumption that this curve has
the right shape, 'delta w' is
squeezed between 'delta
s' and 'AB' plus 'BC'.
As we showed on our little inset
here, 'AB' is the square
root of '1 + ''f prime'
evaluated 'x sub 'k - 1''
squared' times 'delta x'.
What is 'BC'?
Remember, 'BC' was 'delta
y' minus 'delta y-tan' .
That's just your epsilon
'delta x' of your
infinitesimal idea, where the
limit of epsilon as 'delta x'
approaches 0 is 0.
In fact, let me just come over
here and make sure we write
that part again.
Remember what we saw was that
'delta y-tan' was 'dy/dx'
evaluated at the point in
question plus what?
An error term which was called
epsilon 'delta x', where
epsilon went to 0 as 'delta
x' went to 0.
And that's all I'm
saying over here.
In other words, where is delta
s squeezed between right now?
Well, let me put it this way,
delta s itself, by definition,
is the square root of
''delta x' squared'
plus ''delta y' squared'.
That we saw was this.
That was our beginning
definition in fact.
Now if you look at our diagram
once more, notice that since
our curve is always holding
water and rising, that the
slope of the line 'delta
s' is greater than the
slope of the line 'AB'.
Putting all of this
together, we now
have 'delta w' squeezed.
And it was not at all trivial
in putting the
squeeze on 'delta w'.
There was no self-evident way
of saying just because one
region was contained in another,
it must have a
smaller arc length.
We really had to be ingenious
in how we put the squeeze in
to catch this thing.
But in the long run, what we
now have shown is what?
That 'delta w' is
equal to this.
With an error of no greater
than epsilon 'delta x'.
In other words, the exact
delta w is what?
It's the square root of ''1
+ 'f prime 'x sub 'k - 1''
squared' 'delta x' plus 'alpha
delta x', where alpha can be
no bigger than epsilon.
In other words, this is the
maximum error that we have
here because it's caught
between this.
Well, look, as 'delta x'
approaches 0, so does epsilon.
And since alpha is no bigger
than epsilon, it must be that
as 'delta x' approaches 0,
so does alpha approach 0.
In other words, if we now write
'delta w' in this form,
observe that, in line with what
we're saying, this is a
higher order infinitesimal.
And as a result, the intuitive
approach can be used as the
correct answer.
The idea is we could have said
earlier, look, why don't we
approximate the arc length by
the straight line segment that
joins the two endpoints
of the arc.
And the answer is
you can do that.
But you are really on shaky
grounds if you say it's
self-evident that
all the error is
squeezed out in the limit.
This is a very, very
touchy thing.
In other words, in the same way
that 0/0 is a very, very
sensitive thing in the study
of differential calculus,
infinity times 0 is equally as
sensitive in integral calculus.
The whole upshot of today's
lecture, however, is now that
we've gone through this whole,
hard approach, it turns out
that we can justify our
intuitive approach of
approximating the arc length
by straight line segments.
At any rate, this concludes
our lesson for today.
And until next time, good-bye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.